hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my legend of korra episode 7 video i
think we just found the moment where
everyone where the world is gonna turn
against kuvira the fandom as well as the
world inside of legend of korra
everybody needs to give team Bryke a
high five for making everyone cry
because they're happy and cry because
they're really really scared that was
the quote-unquote balance in this
episode really sad but happy moments and
one giant sad scary moment quick
reminder new giveaway starts right now
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video but careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet starting
with top five moments number five Korra
returns to air temple Island they'd
already released a clip really earlier
this of her reuniting with Naga probably
the saddest thing ever if any of you
guys have big dogs too you'll understand
why this was such a cry worthy moment it
also answered where Pabu has been this
whole time I know everyone's been asking
about where he's been in book 4 clearly
just chilling with Naga I was pretty
certain after the rescue at the end of
the last episode that they'd be heading
back to air temple Island just because
that's where Tenzin is as much as other
characters have evolved past them in
terms of spiritual abilities like Jinora
Tenzin is still the character everyone
goes to for advice he's like dad by
proxy for team Korra which is why I was
really happy when he didn't blame Korra
for all the bad things that have been
going on not that I ever think that he
would the episode was all about reunions
this was just the first of many number
four team Korra reunion part one so
first we have the korrasami reunion and
everyone keeps asking about them it's
all in the subtext you could take
whatever you want from it just remember
this is a kid show on a Viacom Channel
I definitely love cores reaction to
Prince Wu but the way he inserts himself
as like a fifth wheel in their
relationship between mokou and Asami bit
of a bummer the Korra did not write
tamaco I think he's right to be outraged
I mean I'd be pretty pissed just
remember that book 4 is all about
evolving as a character it's been three
years so the hope is is that maca will
not continue to be petty although this
is the first time they've seen each
other in the same room so it's
understandable that they kind of slide
into their old habits and for korimako
that just means arguing that's just the
way they say I miss you it's just their
way of saying I really missed you I'm
sorry for all the things that I did not
do like reaching out to you
as much as Cora has evolved as a
character like she's been through this
big crucible she still has a lot of that
adorable bullheadedness whenever we did
get a lot of McCory during book 2 I
always enjoyed the scenes with them
arguing more than I enjoyed the scenes
with them like making out or being
really relationshipy it just feels much
closer to what a normal teenage
relationship would be like teenagers are
supposed to yell at each other they're
not supposed to be super zen that
actually brings up an interesting point
about how old the characters are right
now I think they're around the age of
like 19 or 20 at this point just to
bring it into the real world think of
them as being like college age like
20-somethings at this point
number three team Korra reunion part two
so this is where all the action was this
is where they really slid back into old
team Korra mode car chases and kicking
butt we also get to see some of course
new abilities at play her using
spiritual energy to locate people she
uses the spirit vines the first time but
when she's in the train station she
doesn't need them at all I think the
spirit vines just heightened that
ability so theoretically she could use
that anywhere she is like she wouldn't
need spirit vines to locate someone it's
just more precise when there are spirit
vines around we also see her metalbend
during the chase scene I know everyone
was wondering why she didn't metalbend
in her fight with kuvira I think that's
just because she was off her game like
she was completely unprepared
I think getting her ass handed to her
was something that needed to happen like
it was the big wake-up call that she
needed I know a lot of people thought
that that might have happened when she
was with Toph but that was really just
shaking her out of the funk she was
still really disconnected from the real
world when she met kuvira just remember
she's been out of the loop for three
years they do not have internet in the
world of Avatar although I'm sure
Varrick will find a way to invent it
that'll be the villain for korra book 5
in the comics it'll be like the avatars
version of the internet just to address
the animation during the chase scene it
becomes pretty evident that they've
really upped their game it's a blend of
CG with the cars moving around but when
they're in the Train I feel like Cora's
model it's just the most beautiful that
it's ever been just the shot of her face
even this frowny face I mean it's meant
to be funny just because she's reacting
to Prince Wu but it's one of the most
beautifully animated scenes that I've
seen at least of her face so far it's
like you could take a screencap of this
and just hang it on your wall and it
would look like a painting if I didn't
think that Viacom wouldn't sue me out of
existence
I would totally just upload videos of
Cory
action faces all the time the conclusion
of the chase is also the moment teen
Cora actually reunites I mean they met
before but they hadn't really reunited
they were still kind of reconnecting
it's that big hug that's the moment
where they come together also another
great Cora prinsloo moment I just loved
that her hand is the one to push him
away I feel like this is the best
evidence that Cora is not a dumb
character yes she makes mistakes but she
is instantly able to recognize prince wu
as the douchebag that he is and shun him
in the proper way
also in case you didn't catch it that
train was headed to Omashu which might
give us some clues about where course
headed next there was that scene in the
trailer where she goes up to the temple
it's possible that that's where that
white lotus temple is I know a lot of
people weren't theorizing it might be
easy here's prison I don't know if
that's the case but I am hoping that it
is Omashu
number 2 bolin and varrick do something
good for a change
so let's just start by saying bolin and
varrick two of the smartest but dumbest
characters on the show but that's on
purpose we're just watching bolin slowly
wake up to the way the world really
works Varrick made a nice callback to
him being a mover star
I feel like Bowens been acting like he's
been in a mover this whole time he just
hasn't realized that it's a propaganda
film propaganda films are primarily made
to miss inform people about what's
really going on
it's like Nazi propaganda films they
tell the story that Hitler wants to tell
not the one that's actually going on the
Bender's they run in to tell him what's
really going on everyone who's not an
earth nation citizen is being put into
concentration camps just more World War
two imagery plus you have the fact that
her soldiers here look like Nazi storm
troopers anyway very creepy also as
predicted bolin Varrick heading back to
her public city to tell everyone what's
going on with a weapon during their big
save Bolin has his big hero moment no we
have to save these people I feel like
this is a giant corner that his
character has turned very important
moment also a lot of badass lava bending
the other really important thing you
need to notice is verax machine that he
make Ivers the magnetic machine are
actually it's really EMP when he was
first putting it together I thought it
was just gonna be a giant electromagnet
and it was just gonna pull the machines
back to the wall but the fact that it's
EMP is even better which means they can
make just a giant version of it to take
out all the mechs if you didn't see my
last video I said I'm basically
expecting kuvira to march on Republic
City next that is at
she gets done in the swamp and my number
one WTF moment kuvira is going to
cannibalize the swamp for all the spirit
vines Toph is gonna be so pissed when
she finds kuvira cutting up the Banyan
Grove tree this is actually one of my
earlier predictions I wasn't really sure
if it was gonna happen but Bryke said
the Toph was coming back into the story
they were like just stay tuned there's
gonna be more Toph one of the few ways I
thought she could be brought back into
the story is if kuvira tried to take the
swamp they weren't really clear about
the distinction between the trees in the
swamp and the spirit vines but
apparently they're the same thing or
they're part of the same family a plant
life I like the explanation that the
vines in the swamp are much richer with
spiritual energy than the vines in
republic city
I think that'll explain why that is but
I think that the Banyan Grove tree is
connected to the world tree in the
spirit world I feel like they're gonna
say it's like the same tree that
manifests on two planes of existence I
feel like this is the moment Bryke
intended for the fandom to turn against
kuvira up to this point it was very
ambiguous she was doing a very good
thing
Prince Wu was a total douchebag but now
cutting down the Banyan Grove tree clear
sign that you were a villain the big
question now is is what is tough gonna
do about it I feel like she's gonna kick
the out of those mechs first after
that she's the world's most proficient
metal bender
she's the og metal bender she even said
that Lin and su Yin who are amazing
metal benders never learned it quite as
well as she thought they could which
means that she's like on a whole other
level that being said let me know what
your favorite moment was and what do you
think that topped is gonna do now is she
gonna be in the next episode unless the
next episode is exclusively in Republic
City
I feel like they're gonna have to follow
up with a tough moment where she learns
about what's going on with the bang grow
tree and remember it's not just the
Banyan Grove tree that Koo Vera's
cutting down she's gonna cut down the
entire swamp overall I gave the episode
a solid a plus one of my favorite
episodes so far just because of the
consequences that are implied Mike and
Bryan said something really funny during
an interview where they said that for
all the complaints that the fandom has
about things that Korra does the way the
characters act things that are done and
not done in the plot largely at the time
those complaints are made the questions
have already been answered just because
of the nature of animation because they
have to work so far ahead
like they finished book 4 or they
finished writing it along
time ago before we ever saw a book three
that's just the writing though I mean
they animation takes all that time but
the story is done once they finish the
script things like Pabu cor getting your
together
what tov is up to what The Last
Airbender characters are up to all those
questions have been answered
this is that as they wrap book for up
they basically addressed every major
thing that they had set up every major
plot point everything gets wrapped up by
the end of book 4 so any big question
you have Toph baby daddies Zucco's wife
the new Fire Lord all those things all
answered I know everyone's wondering
about Cora's past lives - that's a big
hanging question I feel like that will
be answered in the finale
or by the finale just to talk about the
animation - aside from like the big
crowd scenes where they have to use a
lot of CG duplication
I feel like book 4 has been the most
beautiful book ever it's like you could
pause any frame of an episode and it
could be this beautiful painting hanging
on your wall even when characters are in
foreground like when Cora's face is
really big in the frame the background
still look amazingly beautiful I know
there been a lot of comments about cores
new look especially with getting her
hair did I personally think that she's
beautiful
a lot of that has to do with the way
she's animated in addition to the actual
look itself I'll be really interesting
to see if Cora's haircut catches on in
real life like you see a bunch of women
walking around with Cora's hair actually
Cora kind of reminded me of gogo from
big hero 6 in this episode with her hair
and just her general attitude like that
short cropped look is gonna be like the
new look for badass female characters
now overall amazing episode I feel like
it did an amazing job of telegraphing
what the action is gonna be in the next
couple of episodes like a very clear
path for teen Cora against kuvira I'll
just end by saying do not worry about
the Banyan Grove tree there will be a
reckoning and its name is Toph beifong
it's gonna happen next week be sure to
subscribe to get my video I will be
posting a Q&A for this tomorrow you can
click here to get that all I the
annotation as soon as I post it and you
can click here for my Korra episode 6
video thank you so much for watching so
let's all high five and say a prayer for
the Banyan Grove tree
you
[Music]